[Music]
[Applause]
so relationship of six education needs
to be age-appropriate
starting from the first year of primary
school by talking about love and
relationships about different kinds of
families the fact that some young people
will be in single-parent families some
will live in extended families some will
live with same-gender families and
they're all are valid that where love
exists that's what counts and of course
this early education should discuss the
correct names for body parts the
physical changes that young people
undergo at puberty and to tackle abuse
to raise about issues about
inappropriate touching about grooming in
order to teach children the difference
between caring and exploitative
behaviors now some people say well that
is way way too young but the fact is
that many children now begin puberty
between the ages of 8 and 12 they need
to know this information before those
changes take place so that panic by the
growth of pubic hair or young girls are
panic by menstruation it's just common
decency to give young people the facts
and it's not encouraging sex is not
promoting sex it's just simply designed
to help enable people to realize changes
in their bodies and the different types
of love that exist I think that if we
keep young people ignorant about these
changes then we are threatening their
happiness and their welfare
moreover children of all genders and
gender identities should share
relationship and sex education lessons
and not be segregated by sex to enable
them to learn about and understand each
other's bodies right from the outset
including boys learning about
menstruation
and both boys and girls learning about
erotic dreams um this is very very very
important because lots of young people
have as I'm told by them themselves they
have deep anxieties about these things
because no one told them it's very
important for young people who have
gender identity struggles to have
information about the feelings and
experiences they're going through to
enable them to understand and feel
comfortable in themselves and when it
comes to it to make informed choices the
fourth point again which young people
are saying is that we get all this
information in school about how bad and
dangerous sex is you know sexually
transmitted diseases child sex abuse no
one tells us about the pleasures and
joys of sex and the fact that sex to me
actually very good for you so I think
certainly from the age of sixteen
onwards schools ought to be saying to
young people yes it's okay to be asexual
or celibate it's okay if you don't enjoy
sex you don't want sex there are some
risks and dangers like HIV but overall
sex responsible sex in the right way is
good for us whether it's solo or with a
partner
it's natural wholesome and with safe sex
healthy and we know from research that
quality sex can have a very beneficial
effect on our mental and physical
well-being you know people who have a
happy fulfilled sexual life do tend to
be happier more fulfilled individuals
across the board and sex is often a way
in which bonding and relationships can
be cemented and strengthened now one
emphasize that of course young people
have a right to know that sex is not
essential for health and happiness
some people are asexual they get by
without sex and that's absolutely fine
however they also need to know that most
people find that regular fulfilling sex
if their spirits and enhances their
lives and relationships the fifth point
which young people have brought home to
me is the importance of overcoming sex
shame in order to chat tackle sexual
abuse sexual guilt causes immense human
misery not just frustrated and unhappy
sex lives but actual psychological and
physical ill health very significantly
it also helps sustain child sexual abuse
adults who sexually exploit youngsters
often get away with it because the
victims feel embarrassed or guilty about
sex and therefore they were reluctant to
report it and this is a this is a thing
that abusers pray on they rely on young
people feeling ashamed and embarrassed
to make them silent so we need to change
that it's not good enough to simply tell
kids to phone Childline if they're
unaware that they are being abused and
they don't have the confidence or the
words to speak out they need to be given
the sense that sexual guilt and shame is
damaging and wrong they shouldn't feel
guilty about these things they should
have the confidence to come forward to
report abuses and I think that if
relationship and sex education did more
to encourage young people to have open
positive attitudes towards sexual
matters and to how to more accurately
report and named body parts and to blow
the whistle on abuse I think the level
of child sexual abuse would go down I
know from talking to young people that
they say that when they're knowledgeable
about their bodies when they feel at
ease talking about sex they feel more
likely and confident to
clothes abuse the six point is how to
have sexual fulfillment most young
people acknowledge that sexual literacy
knowledge understanding is important but
many of them also say that sex or good
sex isn't obvious it needs to be learned
and of course you know yet the gossip
behind the bike sheds and maybe looking
at porn magazines or porn online but
that is not a good relationship and sex
education and we know that in the
absence of sufficient practical
information from parents and teachers
about how to achieve shared sexual
pleasure to get this information many
young people are turning to pornography
with its often unrealistic and degrading
images particularly degrading to women
so to me is pretty obvious that to
ensure happier more fulfilled
relationships in adulthood relationship
with six education for pupils age 16
plus should include advice on how to
achieve mutually fulfilling high quality
sex including things like the emotional
and neurotic value of foreplay including
things like the multitude of raja'na
zones and how to excite them the methods
by which you can achieve sexual pleasure
for yourself and your partner this is
particularly important for boys who
often know very little about the female
sexual anatomy and how to give a female
partner fulfillment if we can
acknowledge that then we need to do
something about it and then say for the
older pupils age 16 plus beyond the
lawful age of consent then they should
know about these things we want people
to be happy and fulfilled in their
sexual lives and to be able to give
happiness and fulfillment to their
partner so it isn't about me me me it's
about shared mutual experience
the seventh point that young people
raise is they want a moral ethical
framework and the current moral ethical
framework is very vague often very
puritanical and I'd like to propose a
tweak of it I think it is important that
relationship with six education
acknowledges diverse sexual orientations
gender identities relationships and
lifestyles but also gives teenagers
guidance on their rights and
responsibilities including teaching
about consent and abuse issues it is so
shocking that we as a society do
acknowledge and are rightly outraged by
child sexual abuse but we do so little
in our schools to actually tackle it and
that needs to change so what I'm
suggesting is that a positive ethical
framework can be summed up in three very
simple principles mutual consent
reciprocal respect and shared fulfilment
the great advantage of these three
principles is that they apply
universally regardless of whether people
are married or single monogamous or
multi partnered hetero bisexual homo
trans or intersex these three principles
apply to everyone in every situation
they're the core three principles that
should guide positive healthy happy sex
and relationships to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit a IDOT TV for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you